thank you so much inviting me they
talked about this paper joint with
Nielsen and named you so they're both in
Nanjing University so all some of you
have heard a bunch of papers that I have
written in the past few years on the
problem with matching with constraints
but I think that's not familiar to
everybody so let me talk a bit about
what this question is okay so the e as
everybody in this room probably knows
the e the e matching theory has been
applied to many many different kind of
like problems in in practice so they we
talked about labor market matching in
the morning maybe maybe matching
matching ex-convicts to jobs and so on
so that kind of application could be
done we have been that researchers have
been helping set up school choice
mechanisms in in in major cities in the
u.s. force for public school choice and
so on the when this application have
been like increasing Li Tong we I mean
people have realized that the many
matching problems are subject to certain
constraints okay which means that well
as the kind of familiar standard thank
you like a matching models have
structures such that well you have a
bunch of firms bunch of workers firms
have certain number of positions fixed
number positions and so on but then
oftentimes they eat that model is not
adequate because they didn't know the
knowö clear concept of capacities number
of seeds so instead the certain certain
regulations might tell you for example
the firm needs to hire at least certain
number of people ie flow constraints
okay
or or seeding which is that the
government might tell you that you can
do certain firms should not hire more
than certain number of workers on top of
even if it is physically possible for
the fund to hire workers and so on
generally be marginally speaking so when
I say my matching is subject to
constraints so I refer to our property
of the model such that well the firm
needs to follow certain kind of function
that a set of subjective workers that a
firm can hire is not described necessary
as a simple capacity conference
definition I you keep using in this talk
alright so like I said the constraints
appear in many many cases and there are
very very many kind of possible
constraints that you might want to think
about so I already mentioned flow
constraints so certain numbers of
workers should be hired in the farm so
one possible application or the real
life case is coming from the so-called
rulers of care program so I suppose many
of you have familiar with this so the
problem is that the in a medical match a
platoon of matching a theory for example
the you know the if you run the simple
Gale and Shapley algorithm well there is
some hotels especially in rural
hospitals rural areas may have hard time
filling any position ok so if you look
at the the practice in the medical
profession oftentimes there are some
constraints or regulations are trying to
promote allocation of doctors into the
rural areas ok so one possible policy
would be to put the e floor of saying
that for each Hospital in this remote
region the remote rural regions the e at
least that a number of doctors should be
placed for example
sealing could be the sort of amira image
here so the in the for example in the
Japanese miracle match which I studied
in a separate paper
the government has gauged sharply
algorithm based matching program but
program but because the government is so
worried about putting too many people in
a certain area namely Tokyo region the
government puts a ceiling on the total
number of doctors who can be placed
through the matching algorithm in each
region of the country so these are
another kind of constraints
it doesn't that the consents doesn't
have to have this floor sitting form of
course like I said there are many
possible ones so for example I could
imagine policy which I call always
hiring constraints meaning that in
particular form a particular worker
should always be hired ok or never
hiring constraints which means the
certain worker can never be hired to a
certain firm possibly because of maybe
national security reasons or something
like that so you certain person cannot
take a certain kind of job there should
be something in the middle also with and
this should be familiar so the in the
school choice well oftentimes there's a
constraint describing saying that well
you know there should be certain balance
of the types of students in the in the
student body in any incoming class of
the school in terms of socioeconomic
classes and so on so the affirmative
action or diversity constraint in
schools like the MU and you might a lot
of these possible constraints and there
are many papers on each of these kind of
types of constraints some of which have
been actually contributed by people in
this room so instead of looking at these
constraints or separately today I'd like
to step up step back a little bit and
think of a general class for conference
meaning that the roughly speaking I
would just say
think of a conference to mean that the
list of all the a possible subset of
workers who can be hired at any given
farm okay so that's a oh yeah but the
very general class of constraints and
ask the following question what kind of
constraint would allow the algorithm
like Shapley or market algorithm
actually to work well in a certain sense
okay a little bit more specifically
more specifically EEE before I make sure
the size work okay okay great
so I will look at uh let me be a little
bit more specific okay so I will look at
the very familiar model standard model
of job matching a la casa la no fault
alright so you have a bunch of forints
bunch of workers there are some transfer
and uh you know people care both about
the identity over your partner match but
also the sorry and so on in that model
we know they we know that the e and a
bunch of conditions most important is
the so called substitute condition we we
get existence of origin very gently boom
which we usually interpret to be an nice
solution because it's efficient and so
on we ask the question what kind of
constraints did say regulation by the
government will still allow the e
equipment keep continue to exist right
of course the e the e the subset of
virgin Kibum in this context also or
correspond to the stable match so you
can actually compute the stable match by
running a button by a generalization
ability for exceptions algorithm so if
we think of a government trying to
organize the center as much market the
motivation is that what kind of
constraints the government interested in
let's say distribution concern
government can still impose certain
regulations and still get a nice nice
outcome and they run the algorithm
nicely okay so that's going to be the
sort of question I'd like to ask but
specifically is this one so what kind of
constraints imposed by the government
still guarantees the existence of
originally so instead of asking this
question directly however like I said
the from the previously teacher we know
that the if the firm preferences are
exhibited
t-then the original even exists right
and indeed they'ii later result such a
good and security says that the in
substitute is pretty much the necessary
and sufficient condition for granting
existence in the maximum dimensions
right so instead of asking this question
of existence of origin cribben I asked
ok ok I asked this question so think of
the following question instead so
suppose that from from revenue function
is such that the Kazakh force sufficient
condition is holes now imagine that the
government impose a constraint on that
farm and firm needs to solve the a
constraint constraint optimization
problem then how then the demand demand
function will be computed now what is
the condition on the government imposed
constraints such that the result of this
constraint optimization problem of the
farm still exhibits the contingency
services condition sort of per phrasing
of the question of the existence
override so that's going to be the main
question I will ask
so that the main thing but then after
that I will make sure if that will
actually translates to de okay that
computer continue to act
programmatically so let me actually
cause it once and
okay okay so this is a first question
and the answer turns out to have a very
simple form okay so we give a bunch of
the cases in which the a substitute
condition will be preserved under
constraints for example the ceiling is a
very easy one sitting again means that
the government imported or imported the
upper bound of the number of lockers the
firm can hire okay so that it seems to
be rather natural that if the government
just truncates
a you know the number of people who you
can hire then they funds demand function
is to behave and it turns out to be the
case okay
the a is a feeling constraints will
speed up the substitute somewhat most
surprisingly the floor constraints also
all satisfies the e satisfy this grant
ie
if the government imposes a requirement
that the farm needs to hire at least
certain number of people a given number
of people then the implied behavior of
the farm still exhibits arrested okay
in addition they always hiring
constraint ie there are a bunch of some
substance of what who should always be
hired and they're never hiring
constraints ie certain certain subject
of workers can never be hired by this
particular farm they keep of satisfying
the serviceable condition as it turns
out and of course their combinations
will satisfy they will satisfy
sufficient condition and but it turns
out that actually they are the only
cases also for other substitute
condition to be a current to be e to be
preserved so in particular the cons not
the very familiar constraints such as
the the type specific upper bound
quarters like affirmative action type
constraints they turn out to actually
potentially cause a problem ie even if
the farms
live in your function itself exhibits
Avista bTW if the government imposes a
Fanta function type constraints then
they implied the behavior might actually
a lead to the failure over the substance
yes substitutability is being important
for existence good question actually
enough commutation flora doesn't
actually we require at least that the a
constraint of different firms should be
consistent ie
there should be at least one feasible
match where as a constraint for each
farm is satisfied but other than that it
turns out that floor constraint is
actually not going to lead the noisy
sense which might actually sound a good
question because typically floor
constraints are a very typical example
in which substitute will be violated in
the matching problem and leads to the
failure of the existence and the reason
here is so you might expect that and we
certainly expected that to be the case
the it turns out that the floor
constraint type problem is known to
cause a problem in matching without
transfer typically ie so if let's say
they think of a school choice where the
a certain school needs to each school
needs to have at least 100 people around
the kids in order to operate if the
number of kids who even willing to go to
the school certain school is less than
100 then there's no way to make sure
that imagine see individual rational
undefeatable here we in a different
model actually where are the data
transfer okay and we allow for both
positive and negative transfer and
unlimited amount actually possibly and
in that means that using this analogy so
E
the government says that a certain
farming is the higher 100 100 workers
and let's say the farm is so like such
an unpleasant place to work for and not
many people would work for that fun the
uprights visa adjust adjust and sorry
goes up so much that the workers will
find it to be actually individual so
that's how why my claim is consistent
with what you proposed
so basically the importantly we are
looking at a market of mucking with
flexible sorry ok question or okay so
all right good
and yeah ok so again so all these are
these four cases types of constraints
and there are combinations exhaust the
craft of all constraints that preserves
the sophistic condition which we agree
part other generous in double
constraints so interval in the sense
that there's a lower bound and upper
bound so it's like an interval and
generalize because in addition we have
we can speech by certain particular
subset of workers who are never hired or
always hired so in that sense is
generalized okay all right so that's the
main result for today using that so we
will look at some structure existence on
structure and so on of averaging ribbon
so it turns out that well or well like I
said as long as these constraints are
satisfied the substitute is preserved
then the existence of regionalism
is kind of standard innovation we can
show the lattice structure of the Royal
Caribbean prices and haha
surprisingly we also get the a bottom of
rural experience
okay so for those of you familiar with
Assyrian in the matching with a transfer
the claim is that under bunch of
conditions the a number of workers
matched to each each farm is constant
across all the stable matchings and in
the as well as far as we know the result
does not quite a work in a market like
those in the ECOSOC afford because you
have a continuous priced prices so you
know if you could have a tool in korea
where the price is a salary of the
workers is exactly like makers Ibaka
indifferent between working and not
working in that case there can be two
origin given where one workers working
there may be another a give him with the
same price we're aware that the worker
is not working so in that sense the
usual human doesn't work but we have a
slightly different division hospitals
and it turns out work three so he's
speaking the set of number of the so set
of Meridian equipment allocations have
the property that if you change the
origin origin price system from one to
another then the number of workers
matched in each hospitals will be the
same in the sense actually the set of
workers set of number of workers matched
with which hospital will be constant
across different sorry-sorry schedules
okay then we talked about the compatible
statics when there are constraints
changes so as you might expect if you
make the constraint stronger then you
know in the sense of maybe putting
making the floor constraints more strict
then you might expect that that means
the farms needs to hire more workers so
workers should be better often workers
our family should be worse off and so on
so we verify that that that type of
claims again because we have a set of
watching Librium
we need to be a bit careful about what
set Ola is the answer turns out to be
weak set order okay so oh yes
okay okay so if if you don't have any
Christian so far
let me actually be a bit formal okay at
least okay the so here the model so I
refer to doctors and hospitals are
following the sort of matching
application the medical much application
but we can think of it as farms of
workers and so on as well if you want so
in any case there's a set of doctors
which I denote by D and when I when I
write the e when I write the e vector is
that Victor of sorry
one for each doctor okay and importantly
the e wage can take any real value and
that stands out to be important pulling
our discussion earlier with Nick the the
on the other side of the market there's
a set of Hostess age okay and we allow
we suppose that there's an outside
option which I denote by H naught okay
so matching mu which I did not buy mill
specifies which doctor works for which
host well if any of course a doctor
could be it could take the outside
option the outcome however over this
market is not just described by a
matching because like I said already
informally we have a model with flexible
transfer salaries so the allocation
which is the outcome of this model is a
pair of a matching and sorry schedule
right muqam is right and I have a
restriction that the e sorry for dr. D
should be exactly 0 if well the doctor
is matched with the outside option so
that the additional restriction for this
to be okay so this is kind of prettier
yes so let me describe the constraint in
a somewhat formal manner now
okay so like I said I want I don't want
to sort of exclude the certain
constraints a priori so in a most
general form that I can think of the
constraint is described by by this
object eh
so script F H so H is a hospital and we
are thinking of a constraint given for
each Hospital separately okay
Oh which by the way it does exclude
certain certain applications like the
Japanese medical magic example that I
mentioned because then the constraints
are imposed over sets of jointly or
subsets of hospitals with that without
caveat the general notion of constraints
is simply a subset of a power set of the
meaning this this collection of PD BTE
this collection includes all possible
subsets of doctors which is deemed to be
feasible at foster age of course if we
only have a capacity constraints upper
bound constraints then this PD PD
collection is made up of all subsets of
doctors for the cardinality is less than
or equal to half the number but we are
not importing that restriction all the
constraints here so we actually allow
for some constraints to come from the
from the affirms from own concern which
I denote by F naught but in addition we
are thinking of a government or
importing some restriction the
constraints which I denote by F
superscript G okay the entire constraint
is given by the by the intersection of
the interesting constraints or
self-imposed constraints and the
governed impose constraints
okay if let's say there are from from
has a natural capacity constraints that
you know the firm can have have space
enough only for 50 people then this if
not describes this kind constraints but
occur if the government in addition said
the family needs to hire a certain
number or a certain number of minority
workers then this is described by F F
superscript G yes
that's a very nice question yeah so you
are you at any rate so one could imagine
having sorry cap sorry floor and so on
in this paper we do not we do not
actually yeah we do not allow that and
when I said actually that's as general
as possible I'm a bit maybe I I'm I'm
saying as if it not clear on that
actually thank you yeah so in particular
we are not allowing for things like
budget constraint where the our farm can
pay at the most certain number of thanks
that important co-education on the
crosswalk on transactions all right so
all I talk about fede beatable matching
so I naturally I said the matching is
feasible if well for each hospital the
set of workers who are matched in that
matching is feasible according to the
according into the constraint associated
with software age coming back to their
conversation with milk the you at least
we assume that the this set of three DVD
collections the constraints are
compatible with each other in the sense
that there at least there exists a one
of edom on matching otherwise well it's
not probably not that interesting so is
everything clear so far you with a help
from Nick and Laura yeah great
okay yeah thanks a lot okay payee so I
have not actually describes a utt yet so
let me do it now okay so this is not
totally is a main part of the paper but
we are a bit more general than many
existing papers so like I said we have a
continuous transfer but we are not
necessary importing a creating ID so
when I write u sub D comma H of s so
this is the dr. Dzau DT when matched
with hostel age
at sorry s okay so we impose the usual
restrictions such as well
the utt should be strictly increasing in
money and also continuous okay and also
we want the money to be important enough
that well to impose this condition which
I which is says that take any pair of
Hospital H and H Prime and then compare
that compare the doctor the UT t for
this particular doctor when matched with
H and H prime then any is sorry yes
there exist large enough Express double
prime that they would rather be matched
with H prime and that also are small
enough are sorry such that they would
rather be matched with H okay so the
money money is important enough of
course the question is that implies this
important thank you yeah okay yeah exist
if yeah so everything is in yeah yeah
how about hospitals well it turns out
that we actually needed to impose
crystallinity in for the hospitals
actually namely so this R sub H Oh a is
living you for hospital age when much
with the subset of doctors a okay and
profit profit is just crazily Nia so the
revenue from hiring a set of workers a -
sorry is being paid okay and that will
induce naturally the demand
correspondence which I denote by X okay
here are the argument of the demand
correspondence is not only the sorry
schedule but also the set of constraints
okay so the farm needs to optimize
within is a feasible set as specified by
the further feasibility question F okay
so if there's no government to impose
constraints then that's a usual or usual
demand correspondence I thought to it as
a innate the mana cost
yes if you're going to impose up the
suitability wise cortland um oh so you
are thinking that you could they find
some kind of substitutes when they when
the utt underling you DS function does
not have to be a quitter vania so that's
a very short answer is that our an IC
doesn't work and the and in particular
it's for us it's actually turned out to
be very important for us to exclude some
kind of income effect actually let me
try to explain it now a little bit but
then come back to it when I talk about a
theorem so like I said the we so we have
this characterization of the classes of
constraints that preserve the sufficient
condition and the sufficiency of
sufficiency of our class for preserving
sufficient condition is based on the
following observation so suppose that so
remember that the so think of a simple
case where we only have fluid
constraints and ceiling constraints ie
the minimum number and maximum number
could be higher in addition to of course
the firm's own concern let's imagine
that the in the what we do is in this
demand if you have let's say so imagine
that the farm is subject to flow
constraints then the industry demand at
any given sorry profile can be described
as if it is actually unique
demand correspondents with four
different sorry schedule from the
original schedule sorry I'm so so this
is the e
this is that constrain the demand and so
what I'm trying to say is that you can
actually show that so let's say this
government imposed the constraint we
just have flow constraints okay meaning
a minimum number of firing that it
behaves as if it is a demand without
constraints but when faced with a
different sorry schedule and sorry
schedule is such that
so sorry could you have this form so
this hypothesis class is Q s prime is
the original sorry plus some epson well
some number a real number plus the
vector a vector 1 which is like entry
with entry 1 for every every worker
meaning that they fun behave as if they
are facing as a uniformly higher priced
by the same amount because if you have a
floor constraint if under the given
price schedule let's say the flow is not
violated
oh I see sorry I said then other firm
you can show that the families actually
you just going to increase the total
number of hiring but by imagining that
the prices for all workers are lowered
by the same amount so the leader team so
in a sense relatively which workers are
more preferred and so on does not change
because the prices are going to be to be
lowered by the same amount
and hence then you basically you you saw
that you hit R 4 but when we do it then
we actually use a lot of properties from
Chris have any idea basically so like I
said we yeah well I'm fortunate that not
the full explanation I apologize but so
this intuition that well if you have a
floor to satisfy then you you can you
can photo imagine that the prices are
lower low for all workers and hence
English the number hiring but you should
not sort of trade off who to hire and so
on differently but this this addition
does not hold if you have an income
effect basically sorry I thought the
best I can given the right now
okay any other comments or questions so
far
all right good okay coming back so we
have a we have a describes our okay now
service to the condition so this should
be familiar to many of you so let me be
a bit quick so fabric should say that if
the sari schedule goes up then for the
for the firm that oh I somehow
mistakenly you have I have three meet
okay yeah so okay so somehow yeah time
wrong okay good
okay so service to say that well or if
the prices of some workers goes up then
the firm can keep hiring the workers
whose prices did not go up and the a
condition for the government D both
constraints to preserve the substitute
condition means that well if the innate
correspondence satisfies the substitute
then II after important government
constraints the demand correspondents
still satisfy the same condition and
this should be true for all importantly
for all substitute variations so that's
that for all parties kind of like
important for getting without okay so
think of a simple case where no there's
no doctor who is always hired or never
hired okay so this is a subclass of
problem we look at and so I already
mentioned what characterizes the
constraint that preserve the service
condition it turns out to be what I call
interval constraints meaning that there
is some number floor and exceeding and
the feasible set is described simply by
all subsets of workers whose number is
between the floor and exceeding and for
this case the theorem is that this the
the class of all constraints that
preserves the service condition is
described by this interval constraint
alright so actually II so answering the
Aleks question so I explained this this
part and this this is pretty much the a
main part of sufficiency condition like
I said if you have a floor or ceiling
then the demand of the constraint demand
will behave as if it's uncle's in uncle
in demand
possibly with modified prices so to the
extent that the original unconstrained
demand is full of the services
satisfied with the condition they
contain demand continue to satisfy the
US although it's a little bit more
subtle because this F prime could also
depend on what s is and so on all right
the necessity for the necessity if we
can we will look at particular subclass
of the concern on the biscuits are sort
of glorified version of the final
contract examples all right okay and
with my miscalculation of time so let me
skip okay oh I have five mommy thank you
okay thanks okay good okay good yeah
it's always good to get more time than
expected great thanks okay great
so this is this interval consent is a
specification which there are no people
who are always hired or never hired what
if we do not impose that constraint then
we get a generalized interval
constraints like I said right and then
well we can show the existence of a
combative equilibrium basically as long
as we we have these constraints but the
exhibit the the constraint demand
continues to have substitute the this Oh
the part which is not totally obvious is
that actually we started out without
imposing crazy linearity for the worker
side but then we actually need a little
bit condition saying that the money is
important enough which we call the
bounded compatibility with that
assumption we get the existence
okay so I already said that we have a
lattice structure of the equilibria but
let me let me focus on that may sound
even more interesting okay so I already
said that you yo oh yes it's scary so
basically yes so oh we have all right
yeah basically we we follow that curve
so go for the proof basically because we
yeah yeah yes the untidy yes so we we
disguise the market and then take the
limit so for the discreet market we can
show the constructively each other
existence and with the enough assumption
on the worker preferences which is not
exactly crystallinity but we have enough
of a continuity and so on we can show
the limit is also limit is actually a
valid equilibrium in the limit so like I
said the it's the phone is not true take
any to varying Caribbean there's a set
of people hired at the same that's not
going to be true because there are a lot
of in differences what we can say
however is a point for take one variable
mu honest and take another equivalent
prices is prime then they exist a much
in mu prime such that well mu Prime and
s prime is a comedian and the between mu
and mu prime the number of workers hired
are the same as well as a set of workers
were not hired so basically if you
compare the set of others I give you
matchings associated with a given radium
a given prices then as such a set they
they have the same the conclusion of the
across different wage any given prices
okay okay so finally comparative statics
so like I said we are looking at the set
of set of origin equilibria
so we should be a bit careful
the ordering so we use a well-known
concept of accept order meaning if you
if you you want to compare two sets of
sets of two to set and one setting is
higher than the other set if well take
any element from the lower set first it
there is something element from the
other set that said that Lata is higher
than the Alfama and vice versa and that
budget so this according to this notion
of order order we get this result which
says the competitive topics so if you if
you lower the ceiling I mean make the
sitting constraint stronger then very
tiny Caribbean prices go down in terms
of this week set order if you put
English the floor then that will raise
up for you a given prices okay for the e
precede the work or move in a sort of
like a reasonable way and associated if
the go prices are higher than what cause
of it are often the phones a lot of
basically so that's going to be the
comparative statics but o importantly
this conclusion is not going to be
necessary true if we were to use a may
be more familiar strong set order which
we people often use all right so great
yes or I tell it I kept yeah I can't I
can't come back come back come up with a
table that over my head but I believe
that I have one yeah I have one
somewhere yeah sorry okay so oh okay so
here's also the last thing so we are
currently working on the a similar
question but now the government think we
are thinking about transfer policy so
now instead of the government mandating
as a set of workers who can be hired in
the a given firm I think of our workers
so the government giving us tax or
subsidy okay depending also a hired and
we have a pyramid to improve these
things I should finish the e a we have a
results characterizing the types of
transfer policies that the government
can impose in such a way to preserve the
preserve the services constant but
that's for another talk I think and okay
so sorry for I think I missed our target
so I should finish now thank you
[Applause]
how you compare the is this kind of
conference fund yeah okay yeah yeah so
we know just a little bit about it so
because we have not done too much of it
for this second project but one thing I
can say is a phone so any in our
framework we can show the form given
given the support that we are given this
constraint in the sense I explained in
today's talk and then compute computer
equilibrium very gently under constraint
now there exists a transfer policy such
that under the transfer policy the
equilibrium equilibrium this same
equation is going to be realized
so in the sense there's a sense in which
any policy based on this constraint can
be replicated by the by the tax and
transfer policy so that that we know but
that that the only thing we know so far
in sum if we think of some kind of so we
we have not we we like to study more
about when actually the tax obviously
[ __ ] it's more preferable or vice versa
but our current framework does not allow
us to ask the question basically it's
gonna be yeah so another project
thank the speaker
[Applause]